it's interesting that dan
uh carlin has been avoiding hitler
as well yeah probably for this reason
probably for this reason yeah i mean but
it's complicated too
because there's a pressure that guy has
his demons
so much he's so this is the the i don't
know if you feel this pressure
but as a creative he feels the pressure
of being
maybe not necessarily correct
but maybe correct in the in the sense
that
his understanding he gets to the bottom
of uh of why
something happened of what really
happened
did get to the bottom of it before he
can say something publicly about it
and he is uh tortured by that burden i
know
you know he takes so much [ __ ] from the
historical community for no reason i
think he's the greatest popularizer
quote-unquote of history
and i wish more people in history
understood it that way
he was an inspiration to me i mean i do
some videos sometimes on my instagram
now where i'll like i'll do like a book
tour i'll be like here's my bookshelf of
these presidents
and like here's what i learned from this
book in this book and this and that was
very much like a
a skill i learned from him of being like
as you know as the historian writes you
know you know i look
i just love the way he talks he's like
in the mud
oh you know he'll be like quote
he inspires me man yeah he really does
to like learn
more and i've read i bought a lot of
books because of dan carl and he'll be
you know because of this guy because of
that guy
um in terms of you know another thing he
does which nobody else
and i'm probably guilty of this he
focuses on the actual people involved
like he would tell the story of actual
british soldiers
in world war one and i probably and
maybe you're guilty of this too
we over focus on what was happening in
the german general staff what's
happening in the british general staff
and he doesn't make that mistake
that's what he tells real history yeah
and and make it gives it a feeling
the result is that there's a feeling you
get the feeling of what it was like to
be there
you